Quindi secondo te comunque per fare una
roba così, tu che dici?
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della
puntata di oggi è "Messaggi Assurdi"
Prima di iniziare sarò molto... Prima di iniziare
sarò pieno di bacilli. Sarò molto sincero
con voi, purtroppo ci si è bruciato
l'hard disk e quindi questa è la seconda
volta che stiamo facendo questo video
In passato è stato fatto con un ospite
meravigliosa, che io rinviterò
purtroppo l'ho già chiamata, Martina
scusami perdonami non so cosa sia
successo. Per cui alla fine sono riuscito
a strappare a botta di c**o la persona di cui
tutti quanti stanno parlando, io sono
contentissimo di ospitare all'interno
degli studios de casa mia
Mark Caltagirone. Allora Mark grazie
mille per essere qui, parliamo di chat
assurde, di messaggi strani che hanno
ricevuto le persone. Se tu non hai visto
questo format, praticamente io chiedo su
Instagram, su Facebook, di mandarmi dei
messaggi vocali e le persone alla fine
mi condividono le loro esperienze tramite Facebook
Ok? - Ok (Gianmanrco) - E' un ragazzo un po' timido, si fa
vedere poco in giro ma direi di partire
subito ad ascoltare i messaggi che ci
sono arrivati. Cavolo sarai impegnatissimo tra i
preparativi del matrimonio, le interviste
Partiamo! - Non so se ridere di più per
quello che mi hanno scritto o per il
nome del contatto sinceramente - Ciccio
Sparalesto scrive "Se letteralmente da s******
violenta al muro. Ciccio sparalesto, bah
mi sembra in realtà nome e cognome per quanto mi
riguarda da passaporto. Ciccio è l'abbreviativo di Francesco e Sparalesto è della famiglia
Sparalesto, come la famiglia Caltagirone,
cioè famiglie che si vedono ovunque
- Ho conosciuto questo ragazzo in un bar, parlavamo, ma io non ero
interessata gli avevo detto e questa è stata la sua reazione
Mi spieghi scusami chi è il mitomane che ti ha mandato questa cosa? Cioè è come se uno ti scrivesse "Ti va
di venire a cena fuori con me?" e tu gli dici "Guarda no non ne ho piacere" - "Ah tanto non ci volevo venire!"
- Mark perdonami se...cioè non è un
pochino come dire "Sto insieme a uno" e
poi non esiste! No? Boh - Ciao Guglielmo ciao ospite, ti ho allegato i messaggi di questa persona che mi scrisse
Diciamo più un suo grande desiderio era di farmi da schiavo
- Leggiamo una battuta a testa Mark, tu sei lui
"In che senso?"... Era più carino perché così almeno c'erano le due voci che si rimbalzavano è vero
- Grazie al cielo registriamo l'audio
separatamente dal video e vorrei
semplicemente proprio al volo farvi
sentire un estratto di quello che ha
detto Martina nella puntata che si è
distrutta
- Io ho deciso che il prossimo che mi
chiede una roba del genere gli dico di sì
Ciao Gu ciao ospite e ciao Enrico ciao Gianmarco, un tizio a caso mi ha scritto e mi ha insultato
Cioè a te i commenti
- Perché?... - Simpatico quello (Gianmarco)
- Simpaticissimo. Magari ecco tutti quelli che mi mandano a cagare su
internet forse in realtà sono solo molto
simpatici e non lo capisco
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, per la serie
"Tentativi di approccio assolutamente
infallibili e per nulla inquietanti" ti
allego una delle ultime perle che mi
è arrivata poco tempo fa - Allora qui scrivono "Leccapiedi cerca ragazza che lo usi come
wc, cospicuo regalo per lei. Se interessata mi contatti".  Ma... - Molti curriculum (Gianmarco)... - Molti curriculum
Ma wc?! - Forse farsi pisciare e cacare addosso (Gianmarco) - Ma davvero?! Sherlock Holmes
Sei in forma Mark. Pamela non ti ingelosire, solamente una chiacchiera, non
faccio domande sulla vostra relazione - Ciao Gu ciao ospite, a me è capitato sabato scorso
che un tipo abbastanza strano ha deciso di adottare una tecnica di rimorchio alternativa dicendomi
che ho la faccia da carbonara perché sembro una tipa decisa proprio appunto come la carbonara
Ma che vuol dire la faccia da carbonara? - Che c'ha un faccione (Enrico)...- Di un piatto, me viene tipo tondo
- Gialla (Gianmarco) - C'ha l'epatite, cioè che faccia è
la faccia di una carbonara
Tipo per esempio per me Mark ha la faccia da acqua naturale
"Laura ci sono 217 alette. Laura ci sono 217... Mark leggila tu
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, ti invio qui sotto uno
dei messaggi vocali più strani che mi
siano mai arrivati, ancora mi sto
interrogando sul suo senso e su come
questa signora suppongo sia arrivata a me
- Ciao come state? Io intanto mi tengo
aggiornata con tuo fratello, con Christian e...
spero che state tutti bene. Ti volevo
chiedere, visto che so che te lavori
ancora a Marseno, li avete ancora i polli, i
pulcini quelli a collo nudo? Se per
cortesia me lo fai sapere, grazie ciao, ciao
ciao. Ciao zia
spero che mi vieni a trovare prima o poi,
in 11 anni che abito in questa casa
non sei ancora venuta - Beh non hanno un buon rapporto con la zia diciamo - "So solo che forse inviando il
messaggio alla persona sbagliata quei
poveri pulcini a collo nudo sono stati
risparmiati" - Ciao sono italiano coniugato, molto
riservato, sano. Mi piacerebbe molto leccarti i piedi, se sei interessata mettine
uno fuori dal finestrino, poi arrivo. Non faccio altro
ne chiedo soldi" - Cioè questa dovrebbe
stare col piede fuori dal finestrino, a un certo
punto uno passa vicino...e poi scappa - Buongiorno ciao Gu ciao ospite ciao a tutti, niente in poche parole avevo
ricevuto un messaggio, da non molto mi conoscevo con una ragazza, mi dice "Vorrei mettere
il mio seno tra le tue chiappe e farti godere". Ciao Gu ciao a tutti, un abbraccio - Ma il seno tra
le chiappe, cioè gemelle contro gemelli? O
gemelle tra i gemelli?
- A incastro (Gianmarco) - A incastro? - Guarda Mark lo sta facendo benissimo (Gianmarco)
- Oddio ma sei perverso Mark - Ciao Gu, io di messaggi strani ne ricevo davvero tanti
Da tempo ho deciso di raccogliere queste perle in un album su Facebook e ne mando due delle mie preferite
- Questo è un poeta, una persona veramente veramente
veramente profonda
specialmente i suoi fianchi gonfiati, "la mia pietra è ora", non domani, non ieri
- No fermi tutti. La quiete che elargiscono e
questa è la foto della quiete che elargiscono...le pecore
Io se le vedessi morirei molto
probabilmente, tu Mark? Eh un fantasma
sei diventato. Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, il problema
non è stata la richiesta in se per se ma il modo
in cui questo sconosciuto me l'abbia
chiesto, trovare totalmente irragionevole qualunque
mia motivazione per non inviare
quella foto. Andando avanti ha continuato a
insistere... - Scusami Mark -  Niente, arrivati a un certo punto cominciava
a essere anche fin troppo inquietante e quindi l'ho
bloccato subito - Brava, hai fatto
benissimo! Comunque posso dire una cosa?
Queste cose dei piedi a volte arrivano
anche a me, non so se anche a te
ti chiedono mai una foto o cose così. A parte che ho visto che un sacco di persone si fanno delle
foto con te ultimamente, posso farle vedere?... Ma la domanda è: ti è mai arrivata una
richiesta così assurda? E hai detto sì o no?
Ah non l'avrei mai detto. Mazza che bravo
che sei a farlo! Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video, io non avrò mai
abbastanza parole per ringraziarti
Mark Caltagirone per essere venuto qui
So che non ti sei fatto vedere in tv, non
ti sei fatto vedere da nessuna parte
e secondo me è la cartina tornasole
della tua umiltà. Puoi sposare una
showgirl forse perché proprio gli opposti si
attraggono, c'è chi si vuole far vedere
troppo e chi invece non si vede per
niente, ed è pazzesca questa cosa. Ringrazio
anche voi ragazzi per averci seguiti
Io qua sotto vi lascio i profili di Mark
Caltagirone e che dire, fatemi sapere
quali sono stati i messaggi assurdi che
avete ricevuto e soprattutto scusatemi
ancora per questo intoppo che c'è stato
con l'hard disk. Adesso va sostituito
molto probabilmente, magari sostituiamo
anche quell'hard disk del tuo cervello Enrico eh?
Siamo sempre più vicini al milione,
possiamo dirlo? Basta queste ansie, ormai
c'è un countdown verso il milione e che
dire se vi divertite e se vi piace questa
rubrica in particolare iscrivetevi a
questo canale, attivate le notifiche per
non perdere i prossimi video. Noi ci
vediamo con un altro Vita Buttata sempre
giovedì prossimo alle 14. Ciao
Passami un secondo questo che glie lo metto
Ci facciamo un selfie? Mazza sei fotogenico da paura       - Aspetta aspetta, voglio farmelo pure io
- Grande - Grazie - Grazie Mark
Occhio non spegnere luci che poi
rischiamo di andargli addosso